[Applaudissements]
c'est magnifique ça sourit même mon slip
il est parti à l'autre dû renoncer big
ben si je perds j'arrête l'émission
pendant que tu as raison des panneaux
les saillies au lido vim
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et il ya les micro de rugby mais qui
s'est dit on va chanter je sais pas
c'est faux et paillage bien sûr ce soir
soit fait des pauses photos érotiques
ah d'accord judith y en aurait pu leur
montrer des photos érotiques fait défaut
ce papa je les ai vus c'est énorme
énorme non mais après quand je t'ai vu
cgt hyper lourd date j'ai été le voir je
dis je t'adore et touche c'est simple
assemblage est un petit peu le monde non
plus mais je le dis beaucoup de fois et
tourner ça fait toujours plaisir parce
que c'est vrai que les gens le disent
avec le sourire plutôt que prendre des
tomates dans la gueule
non mais c'est pas il donne envie de
j'ai envie de jouer ou non avec lui je
vous donne envie de jouer il ya des mecs
tu as envie de coucher avec lui on joue
ou non son couchant copains et ce n'est
pas nous a vu un truc avec une ex vous
arrange mais maintenant je vais vous lui
je suis sûr que doit de super copain
avec ses textes
non c'est un amour j'ai pas de sexe
n'est pas l'ex illa kané le présent à
wil présent la raison et futurs le
présent est d'accord